obviously officer Darren Wilson was not
indicted by the grand jury in the murder
or the shooting death of Michael Brown
what yeah shocking right you're totally
shocked we've got some video to show you
what's happened basically since then and
then we'll rewind after that disperse
immediately or you will be subject to
arrest do it now the mcdonalds the
window is broken into again we saw a
couple other stores broken into and
looted teargas has been throwing water
bottles we witness being thrown at
police this tear gas just drop right
near so it's gonna get very bad here if
we don't have mass they're throwing it
back there's a lot of bean bags being
shown at teargas what you're looking at
is the aftermath of the grand jury
deciding not to indict officer Wilson
that's one police cruiser that is fully
engulfed right now and then if you just
turn to your right our photographers
psyche Moss is gonna get you that one is
almost finished burning okay so that was
obviously a lot of the fallout the
evening of the decision now I want to
point out here because I think this is
being lost that what happened here was
that the grand jury decided to not send
this to trial this was not the trial
itself right I think it's important to
say that because no one's really saying
that on the news this thing didn't even
get to trial there's a dead person and
somehow it didn't get to try being armed
dead person yet how many people unarmed
it shot at by at least 35 feet away yeah
unarmed 35 feet away shot dead shot dead
with six bullets 12 of them and I mean
and six of them missed them and the
grand jury said that's not enough
evidence just to get this truck
meanwhile yeah there's a black cop in
st. Louis County who is being charged
with felony prosecution by that same
prosecutor because he hit somebody in
the hand and broke three of their
fingers he's being prosecuted no grand
jury he's just gonna prosecute him for
felony Jimmy are you implying
some sort of racial element to this I
think I'm am implying that that
prosecutors a racist corrupt
transparently corrupt and so is the
police chief so is there in Wilson so is
that whole Police Department my question
is when you see an out-of-control police
department like this they're tear
gassing that the news reporters again
right okay so when does the feds come in
and go you guys aren't a police force
anymore you all have to go home Frank so
we'll get to the reaction in a second
but just the first part that this was
the grand jury decision not even trial
how many people do you think even
understand that even even the people
that are out there at night that are
upset how many people actually get what
really just transpired I think they get
I'm gonna get I mean in general no one
understands the grand jury process it's
a confusing process I mean it's for
people who haven't even the prosecutor
doesn't understand everything she
revealed it he revealed yesterday that
he has no idea how the grand jury system
works and he set it on live TV yeah
that's exactly right the fact is there's
no I mean they can reconvene another
grand jury and prosecutor like they'll
think a study could try ten times you
know or you didn't know that so there
isn't anything like double jeopardy when
it comes to the interior hasn't charged
double jeopardy is for you're charged
with a crime yeah so it's incredibly
unlikely because who would do that but
that said it could happen and and the
you know if say he this guy just got
reelected he ran he was on a post love
McCullough for another service county
prosecutor would you oppose them yeah
who did that what we run on you know
there's nothing nothing you can grab
onto um but theoretically like if he
were recalled which is available to
Missouri voters then another prosecutor
to come in and we can either convene a
different grand jury present the case
differently or just charging outright
based on the evidence they have and I
think based on what you saw in the grand
jury testimony you can see where a
conviction on Darren Wilson would be
difficult right that that that's clear
election in the trial that you didn't
get what if he were try because there
are witnesses who give conflicting
reports and a jury would hear those
happens in every case so it will you
know Abraham saying because it might be
difficult to prosecute it he's not going
to get every case like the whole point
because I'm not
and obviously you are obviously
obviously he should have gone to trial
because there's unquestionably enough
there in the grand jury theoretically
shouldn't even have heard the people who
the defense would have eventually called
but the fact is the defense would
eventually call them so you can see
where well it might have been reasonable
doubt you might had a tough time getting
12 jurors but the fact of the matter is
nobody even that the defense witnesses
right the witnesses who spoke on
Darryl's as bath and who's now testimony
we've been able to really don't know who
they are but it's no one cross examined
them right so which would you know and
you were like so when he appeared to be
reaching might that be the kind of thing
that somebody would do after they've
been shot in the stomach but that might
opinion what he was doing with his hands
is that possible and the guy would have
said well yeah probably what's love
whatever John stomach so but yeah so I
think they don't know but they what they
do know it doesn't matter whether they
know the specifics they know they know
that justice was not done they know that
this guy not only is he allowed to walk
free didn't even have to didn't even
have to do anything to walk free he
didn't even have to hire Johnny Cochran
and sell a story and win a case cuz he
had a lot of money they'd the system
didn't even try they just let the
tailgate the Johnnie Cochran literally
would have come back from the dead to uh
to probably actually he probably
wouldn't've been huge on it